Welcome everybody. It is the third of April. Hopefully you guys got to pull some good April fools day jokes on your friends and family. That's always fun.
Hopefully your weather is getting better. It's getting nice here in Minnesota. Let's start to perk up a little bit.
One question that came in this week that I wanted to address. It was a question about THC and CBD. So we're talking about the use of medicinal marijuana.
When we talk about THC and CBD, THC of course is the psychoactive component of the marijuana work hemp and CBD is the non psychoactive component. They contain cannabinoids. That's the technical term. There are over a hundred different types of cannabinoids and cannabinoids are not solely found in marijuana and hemp plants.
There are found in other vegetables as well. There's numerous different cannabinoid receptors that have been discovered on cell membranes and neurons and all sorts of different cells that have all sorts of different actions and functions that are far from just the psychoactive component that.
So many people are interested in when they talk about legalizing marijuana use.
So I benefacted. I just did a blog post just recently on the different the main different cannabinoid receptors and what they do. So make sure you look at our blog posts.
I'm doing a lot more writing and bloggy lately. So there's a lot of information on our blog post about a lot of different things. So make sure that you're looking at that on our website too. That's on the resources page of our website.
And you'll find a lot of interesting information hopefully there.
So how would a cancer patient use THC or CBD while a number of years ago I would say that THC is the component that would be used to help kill cancer cells and CBD would have other medicinal purposes.
However, recently within the last two years there's there's just dozens of studies coming out on CBD's effect on cancer and its beneficial effects to help kill cancer cells as well.
So things are changing as studies are coming up. I interesting to note I did have a patient tell me the other day that her oncologist said that there's that he would gladly use CBD or THC if there was any studies on it, but there's just no studies on it.
Well, all the layperson would have to do is go to Google and do a Google scholar or a pub men search for THC and cancer or CBD and cancer and you will find literally hundreds of studies and literally every one of them show its efficacy for cancer.
I have yet to see a study that say CBD does not help cancer patients, some way or another it can help cancer patients, at least in all the studies that have been performed.
So just for a doctor to say that he has yet to see any studies he has yet to look he's probably yet to read a published journal article since he graduated from school of events, but that's typically the scenario that these people find themselves in they're not looking at recent literature.
So yes, when you graduate when I graduated 37 years ago, there were no studies on THC or CBD and cancer now there's literally hundreds.
But so let's talk about the different uses of THC and CBD so CBD has become a more and more available.
It's legal in all the states to use we sell it on our store there's good and better and best as far as CBD products that are out there.
Maybe I should say there's poor there's good there's better and there's best there's a lot of really cruddy CBD products.
One of the things that you have to be careful with CBD and THC is its purity because hemp is a wonderful plant to clean the soil it cleans the soil by sucking up all these bad particles into the plant.
And not using an organic CBD or THC product can lead you to basically toxifying yourself so you want to make sure it's organic.
I know we just talked about this on a zoom call a few weeks ago, but these questions come in again.
So the other challenge that I give you is to make sure that you know we want to be available to answer all these questions as they come up but make sure you go through the past zoom call videos.
Because I go into much more detail and some other things that I'm not going to get into tonight about the other values of water soluble CBD nanoized CBD and the other values of THC.
We can't legally sell in Minnesota we don't have that on our website you will be able to buy that except through some people that are trying to get it in the hands of cancer patients and if you do desire to have some THC product we can give you the names of places that you can get it from but we can't sell them.
So THC and CBD both have great efficacy for cancers and they should be THC should be used very carefully because it's psychoactive and it can have a lot of side effects CBD you don't necessarily need to use that quote unquote carefully.
You should always start with a smaller dose of workup you should get a pure product but it's not going to have any major side effects in a person other than maybe a little bit of drowsiness which it can actually really help if you take it before medic and help you with sleep so CBD has all sorts of other wonderful benefits outside of cancer.
From a medicinal purpose that it really makes it a valuable product for people.
Okay, I'm going to open it up for questions that you might have so let's see if we get some participation here.
Dr. Connors, I have a question.
This is Donna from Arkansas.
When I've got some CBD oil that I've been putting on my knees because I've been having a lot of extreme pain in my knees and I've gone to the chiropractor and I spent two months going to three times a week kind of fit really helps.
So you went because of the pain of your knees, is that what you said?
Yes.
Okay.
And she really wasn't able to help me.
I mean, she took some low dose x-rays and so it's not a cartilage thing.
We think it's nerve possibly from the cancer.
So my question is as a CBD oil, the kind that you can take it either internally or it's like a cream.
So internally or you can just rub it on and I didn't know which would be best.
So let's say you've painted both these, is that right?
Yeah, it was the weirdest thing.
I mean, I had no pain all these years and then all of a sudden the inside of both knees at the same time started having problems.
And now it's been almost a year and now it's radiating down into my ankles.
Okay.
Okay, so if it is from the cancer, it would really do you little to no good to put the CBD at the site of the pain there.
Because the chance that you would have metastasis to both these in the same spot at the same time is about zero.
So, but you could have referred pain from okay, the knees are integrated by your third lumbar nerve.
So if you have some metastasis to the lumbar spine, you could get referred pain down both sides, especially if it's centrally located metastasis, you could get referred pain down both nerve pathways and feel pain down at the receptor area, which is down at your knees.
But then putting, you know, putting a lotion or anything else locally is not going to do anything.
You have to go to the site of the problem, which would be then you would put if you wanted to use it as a topical that you would put it in at about the third lumbar, third, fourth lumbar area in your low back.
So that's where you would apply it.
Right.
And that could be beneficial.
It can be anti-inflammatory and that would help with the inflammation there, which is really what's causing the pain.
So taking it orally also now see does CBD is that good for pain taking it or like yes, it can be different people react to it differently, but typically you need a fairly high dose for it to really make a difference with pain.
So I don't know the dosage of the product that you're taking.
So you'd want to look at that also.
Yeah, it's a good product and it is organic.
Okay, good. Well, then then you'd want to you'd want to start with a smaller dose, maybe I would still say you have to start with at least 30 milligrams a day and then bump up from there to see if it makes a difference orally.
To see if it's going to make a difference.
Yeah, I would say I would say take it several times a day.
Okay.
The other so she did took X-rays of both your knees and she didn't see any degeneration or decrease in joint space.
No, it's really it's more of a nerve thing and I've had problems since I've been diagnosed just really before I was diagnosed with cancer with having nerve white hot pain.
And my leg and in my arm that last probably about 10 minutes is the most appreciated pain I've ever experienced in my life.
And but it goes away.
The last about 10 minutes it goes away.
Yeah, it goes away and then it will be a long time before it comes back and does it again and I'm thinking maybe the way I'm sitting, you know, maybe that's causing the I don't know.
Yeah, I would say that if so how often is it happening now?
The last time I see it happened last.
No, it's a couple years ago and then I had it again probably about six weeks ago.
So it's real sporadic.
Okay.
And then it only lasts about 10 minutes.
Yeah, but that's that's 10 minutes of absolute health.
So I would say that yeah, it's that's that's probably a nerve inflammation issue.
And you have to dig a little bit to figure out where it's coming from.
It could be as high as as in the brain.
So especially if you're getting it in the hands and the legs.
That it has to be has to be from the from the parietal lobe.
Yeah.
So that's where CBD could be beneficial for that.
So, but that would be taking it orally.
Okay.
You know, Arkansas has a law now that PhD is legal in our state.
I haven't really set up anything.
They're showing the process of getting all the clinics.
You know, set up for it.
So it's not available as of right now.
That would help the pain.
But I don't really want to do.
I don't want to smoke it.
I don't want to have a lung issue on top of everything.
Right.
If you have a person has chronic pain.
So not this intermittent sharp pain.
If a person had chronic pain where it's just maybe a grade six, seven, all the time, or eight, nine, or higher, all the time.
That's where smoking marijuana can really be beneficial.
And we've even seen people get off their opioids by doing that.
And it doesn't have to be smoking.
You could actually take it.
You know, you know, you know, a cookie or something like that as long as it's baked.
So you could get the THC out of it.
But it will make you feel a little loopy.
And some people don't like the way that feels.
But it can be extremely beneficial for pain.
And for it seems to at least start our experience.
It seems to work better for those who have never or rarely ever used marijuana in their life.
People that have used marijuana in the past quite extensively.
And it made me have it for 20 years.
It seems not to work as well for them.
Because there are CBD receptors are already up regulated.
But people that have not used it.
I've had people where they just where they choose to smoke it.
They'll just take one puff literally one puff a day.
And that can dock their pain down to manageable levels.
So that's an option to take it a THC in a in a very concentrated form what you would use for.
It's like killing cancer.
So AKA Rick Simpson oil.
That will make you feel really loopy.
It really.
It puts you out of commission for sure.
So I would not recommend that unless you had serious serious chronic pain.
Yeah, no, I mean, I don't even take anything for it.
Unless it gets really bad.
I can't take some to merit as well as once in a while.
I'll have to take an aspirin.
You know, this helps the pain because.
We have a business and I today I was up and down off of the one turn.
But that truck all day.
And you know, that's definitely hurts my need.
Yeah, that is that could be hard.
I would really.
If you haven't both these.
I would consider doing on your low back.
Now that being said, you know, not questioning your chiropractor and her x-ray skills.
The media.
Miniscus of the knees.
That's that that's that inside part of the knee where you said you have where the pain is.
It is the most common area for degenerative arthritis.
So that wouldn't be that would that would be actually quite common for a person to commit and say I have pain inside of both my knees.
And it's in its degenerative arthritis.
And if that's the case, then using something topically can be beneficial.
And I always think of curcumin also because it's an anti inflammatory and Boswellia and ginger.
That all those are all good anti inflammatory to.
Yeah.
Yeah, I'm taking your.
You're too clear.
Okay.
Yeah.
So.
And if if it if it is a degenerative joy, then think of also glucosamine and condroitin.
Right.
I don't think so because it moves around my knee.
I mean, my knee area, sometimes it's in the front.
Most of the time it's on the inside of both.
But it can be anywhere in the back on the outside.
Well, that that's not uncommon for for for degenerative arthritis, though.
Okay.
So that that wouldn't be an uncommon fighting.
All right.
Very good.
Well, thank you very much.
Oh, you bet.
Here's another question came in on the chat.
When reducing the dosage of CBD.
Is it necessary to gradually reduce the dosage or could you do it all at once?
If it's a CBD or THC, you could literally go off of it all at once.
So if you were wanting to get off of it for whatever reason, you could just stop.
There's no need to reduce the dosage.
Going to cold turkey on it as far you're not going to have any issues.
Okay.
Any other questions?
No.
Well, thank you for being tonight.
Sorry about my voice.
I can't talk today.
And got this little crud that's going around.
And hopefully I'll be better by next week.
And I just will be prayed for everybody and wish you all the best.
We'll talk soon.
Thank you.
We're praying for you too.
My mind.
Thank you, Dr. Connor.
Oh, you bet.
Bob and best wishes to you.
Oh, you too, Liz.
Bye-bye.